congratulations on the movie
i do want to start with an unrelated
question though because i really love
seeing the continued work you do for
your alma mater so i wanted to know
during your time at auburn is there
anything that happened there that you
find
still influencing the work that you do
as an actor and a producer now
that you hope other students can
experience themselves i think
just the time there you grow up when you
go away to school uh
that you gain the freshman 15 pounds
because you know your mom isn't there
making you dinner and you get to make
your own choices and then you realize
you're drinking
beer and eating wings and pizza all
those things that you love and then you
realize
probably shouldn't be eating this
there's a reason why you know your
parents make you eat vegetables but
that's all stuff that you learn on your
own so it's about that coming of age and
the bonding experience
that you have away at school which is
why my heart is breaking for college
kids
all across the world right now yeah and
i know i know how you feel in that
respect but the stuff you're doing over
there
is very cool and i have a feeling it's
making a big difference yeah we want to
make sure that they
uh have some some good memories from
this year so we we just wanted to
uh give them some some kernels to play
with absolutely
so you know i can't not ask you about
working with ann on this and
maybe in particular did the two of you
ever swap villain notes
because these characters are very
different but i feel like the grand high
witch
and mob both require you to to kind of
lean into the extremes with those
characters so did you two ever discuss
that
oh no no we were busy discussing you
know
normal stuff like kids and uh
cooking and nail polish and you know
she's just a sweet sweet woman
and uh between takes we were just
laughing we laughed a lot
because she would come in and her you
know
grand high witch outfits and just she
she just turned it on and and turned it
off
so beautifully i would believe it so
uncollider we play a movie making
would you rather game often and this one
question feels like it would apply to
you right now
would you rather work with a real animal
or a cg creature
cg creature i would rather work with a
cg creature what would happen
if you were offered a role working
opposite or real animal
or bug and it happened to be a tarantula
i wouldn't take the part it's just
somebody else who likes those things i
mean i saw a tarantula
outside my trailer just this week and
there's no way
on god's green earth that i would do a
scene with the turtle
no i understand that your character in
this movie
is a healer but in real life do you have
any suggestions for some folks out there
who might need some extra healing right
now to get them through certain things
i would say call your priest and go to a
doctor for sure
go to doctors don't heal yourself don't
read
the internet to see what your symptoms
are because symptoms match
everything else yeah i need i'm a big
googler so i need to take that to heart
a little more
diagnosing trust me you always give
yourself the worst possible disease
yep so another thing that i was reading
about
was your friday night best picture group
which sounds like the most amazing thing
ever so twofold question with that one
first what is the best character you've
dressed up as
yet well i have to say that other people
in the group dress up better
than i do like amy adams and uh
elizabeth banks adam shankman
uh melissa mccarthy they they all
dress up so much better than i do
revisiting those movies
and seeing if they've held up or not has
that influenced the kind of projects you
gravitate towards now as an actor and
producer
well um we just started doing that
during a quarantine um
but it made me i think i will definitely
going forward want to make sure that
um the stories are uh
ones that will transcend time you know
and this
the storytellers are a huge part of that
who is getting to tell their stories and
how they tell them
i like the sound of that and i'd like to
bet you're gonna do it thank you so much
for your time today and huge
congratulations on the witches
thank you